from my experience growing up especially  in university seeing on the outside  having casual sexual relationships as  this fun thing it's not fun and nobody  thinks it's fun especially women so if  you're around other girls and they're  like oh yeah i hooked up with this guy  none of you guys are actually enjoying  that and i think that's a lie that women  tell each other i think because they  think other people don't care and  because if you do it it makes you feel  bad enough that you're like well i don't  want to look at that me feeling bad is  not healthy or there's something wrong  with you right and it's unpleasant  enough that you're like well i'll just  you know keep going it's already  happened there's nothing i can do about  it might as well be okay because what am  i going to do about it if it's not okay  for anybody out there who's thinking  maybe i don't want to do that it's not  fun it doesn't make you feel good it's  really lonely it's not a good idea